hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna just checking in on yeah I'm just
checking in on you this isn't even a
podcast this is just me poking my head
into your cubicle your office door your
[__] cardboard box wherever you live
in wherever you're working whatever you
do it are you making America great yet
we're gonna make it great again remember
when it was great that's gonna happen
again making America great again what's
going on how are you I'm in a good mood
my my lovely daughter has entered a new
phase of just non-stop crying and I
think she's gonna be a Ric Flair fan
because the only thing I could do to get
her to stop was you know those exercise
balls that uh the ladies use them you
know cuz they're always trying to work
their glutes and their [__] thighs
because that's where they put the weight
on you know guys they're always over
there doing sit-ups doing that [__]
right dude [__] from Rocky hanging
upside down well maybe if I hang upside
down and [__] do a sit-up you know
that'll offset the [__] nine slices
of pizza I'm gonna have tonight the
pizza wins okay you don't need to hang
upside down you don't even need to do
[__] you don't really even need to do
sit-ups what you need to do is you need
to get some salads in your life you got
to start looking at bad food like it's
some [__] chick that you know is
great in the rack right but it's just
you can't bring it home to your parents
she's a [__] lunatic that's that's
what bad food is and the food version of
great in the rack is salt sugar high
that's all this right just sends you
[__] through the roof you're like yeah
you know and you just keep grabbing one
[__] handful after another is
something in the back of your in the
back II head is just screaming no like
when you're dating a psycho why am I
gonna go out to a farmers market with
this [__] lunatic why am i pretending
that the
a relationship here you have a bang of
chicken she's got a window right behind
her bed and a half way through banging
are you like what if I just opened this
and [__] crawled out you know I'm sure
women have thought that you know what I
mean
laying on their backs getting [__]
railed by some sweaty [__] I don't
know banker assistant and then he's got
a skylight going what if I was like
spider-man right now I could just some
[__] webs that just go right up and
out of here leave them all confused half
excited on the bed that's what they need
to have in the future everybody they're
trying to have better cameras on your
cell phones better recorders okay and I
don't know something else whatever the
[__] they always have to be three
examples so you fill in your last one
this podcast will be interactive why
don't they come up with something that
when you're with somebody right you
could just you just hit a [__] eject
button like every house has like a
[__] like even if you're on the
bottom floor you just got to stand in
the right place and remember that those
old-school offices would they would like
send messages around through that little
[__] vacuum thing you know you put
the thing in the tube just to just
disappear and go into somebody else's
office sort of the original [__]
emails they should have that for people
you know and yeah I'm telling you I
didn't like the way you talked to my
sister and just remember we have that
dance recital on Saturday and you just
said I know you just walk over to the
[__] portal and you're just gone
honey stop it you're scaring me honey
you still there she walks over and you
just [__] gone then it be the new
thing instead of getting dumped you got
poured hold what's wrong with Maggie oh
she got born hold right in the middle I
think she was nagging him you know how
Maggie is she's very very particular and
she I know I love her too I love her too
but she can be Hoshi can be she's a lot
she is and then that's when the other
girlfriends go she is a lot she's
definitely a lot you know and then they
[__] clink their little [__] glass
a rose a
whatever it is women do in the afternoon
ladies what do you do in the afternoon
what is that little wine break you take
you know like your [__] Ernest
Hemingway you know that's why I want to
say I got it I'm gonna say something
like that at that writers thing on
Sunday just talking about how much I
booze now because I [__] sit in a
writers room anyway so you know anything
that keeps my my daughter quiet during
this phase that she's going through
which is [__] awesome even though
she's crying her brains out now she's
like she's like looking at [__] you know
she's like taking it in and everything
it's an amazing thing right so we got
this exercise ball the thing that the
ladies have right now maybe someone like
Bill Clinton it puts on weight like a
[__] right
remember his big milky [__] thighs
the is during his first semester or
whatever the [__] they call it his first
trimester of being president remember
that [__] when he'd go jogging and those
[__] short shorts all I do anyways
you sit on that exercise ball okay and
you bounce up and down and the only
thing that keeps it quiet as if I fight
the [__] I don't want to bounce it up
and down if I just keep going you know
and as much as it was driving me nuts as
much as I was feeling like old spine
compacting every time we went down I
held out this this glimmer of hope that
maybe she's gonna be a Ric Flair fan Ric
Flair fan it's not easy to say so
anyways how was your Thursday you're
almost there to get they give you a
paycheck yet that was always the best
you get your paycheck then you go out
for lunch right dude you want to get a
beard what's that one but just have one
well just have one you know that whole
[__] thing what the [__] is it you
know what it is is quality of life folks
and say what is it about life that you
just can't you can 90% of the time
you're not doing what you want to be
doing you know if there was no I guess
if there was no infrastructure or
society man we probably only live for
[__] 30 years but just imagine for 30
years you could do it over the [__]
but then no one would have done anything
and no one would have taken the time to
make a beer factory so then you wouldn't
have a bar and then what would you do
you just be sitting around trying not to
get eaten by animals all right so a
there we go we just figured out why you
have to go to work every week but isn't
Thursday exciting I think that's the
point I'm trying to make here Thursday's
are exciting because they give you that
piece of paper with the numbers on it
and then you write your name on the back
of it and then you go down to those
[__] crooked banker [__] you give
them that piece of paper with the
numbers on it and then they give you a
piece of paper back that added more
numbers to the numbers that were
previously on that piece of paper and
then you walk around buying [__] isn't
that what you do I have no [__] idea
there was another thing I liked about
that old guy who smoked 12 cigars a day
and he lived he's 109 he's still going
like one of the oldest World War two
veterans out there what I liked about
him was he paid cash for everything paid
cash for everything you know just
completely you know I wonder if you just
slipped through the cracks after a while
if you came into this world and you just
paid cash for everything and you never
went on the internet you know somebody'd
still take a [__] selfie with you and
then that would be in everybody like
who's this guy who's this mysterious guy
that's never been on the internet and
pays cash for everything you know all
the advertising world would be all
obsessed we don't know what kind of
toothpaste he uses we can't have that
starts [__] spying on him with like a
drone and [__] I don't know what's going
on here I just had a bowl of cereal
maybe that's what it is I thought it was
a healthy bowl do you guys like the Chex
family of cereals I'm big on the Chex
families
speaking of which so many cereals have
just [__] disappeared when my wife
was pregnant when she was preggers when
she was pregnant she was requesting all
these [__] cereals you know from back
in the day for some reason I'm thinking
to be the ending of Star Trek right now
Wow
she wanted alphabets they don't [__]
make those anymore some somehow you can
go to Target you know but that involves
that involves like you know going to a
mall it's one of those anchor stores you
know which is the goal of anybody with a
small business someday I'm gonna be an
anchor store and a [__] mall then
then I'll be happy right and you got a
[__] deal with the parking garage and
then you're like following somebody like
a serial killers they're trying to get
back to their [__] car and then they
get in there and they start checked the
text messages and the person behind you
starts beeping and it just becomes like
you know what it just becomes one of
those things we just have to be like you
know what [__] this serial [__]
alphabets [__] boo berry Count Chocula
Frank and Barry sugar corn smacks
Honeycomb [__] all of these cereals I
don't know where they are anymore you
know what they're like they're like old
music acts that play casinos you know
what I mean it's like loverboy this
somewhere right now this weekend and
they're gonna sing weekend right there
somewhere doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
you won't a piece of my heart tell me
that lead singer didn't kind of look
like Dan Marino back in the day
anyways that's why like old cereal is
like they're on the casino tour they're
not in grow my grocery stores as far as
cereal goes food in general when you're
in all the grocery stores that's you're
at the height of your career right
you're Bruno Mars you're doing the
[__] Prince thing at the Grammys
right and then somewhere you know but
you're on the deer right at the [__]
mid-level shelf to your headline it
maybe even the top shelf a right at
[__] eyeball level whatever average
height is your right [__] there
sandwiched between the check serials of
check family of serials and then you got
the cornflakes on the other side you're
right there your big stupid [__] face
and whatever sugary horse [__] you're
selling to the public all right and then
somewhere along the line it just you
know you
run out of hits you collaborate with the
wrong people people's palates change and
then you get you get you get pushed out
you know you start going to those places
where you know you can only get them in
certain cities you're only in target
like Michelob Michelob light Michelob
light the only place I've been able to
buy that was in the city of New Orleans
once Michelob Ultra came along it just
completely [__] over Michelob light I
don't know where it went
so first beer I ever got drunk on I love
that beer I love me some make a long
black and I don't know I know what the
[__] I'm talking about just asking you
guys you like to check cereals you know
I didn't want to do a whole 80s [__]
comedy routine on cereal did I you know
[__] it let's keep going then you got
Wheaties Wheaties is like the Frank
Sinatra you know like the Rat Pack like
they're never going away that timeless
[__] classics you know fly me Toto
home he just [__] [__] that's really
not good for you [__] Bruce Jenner
didn't eat this that's not why he won
the gold medal in other words he's a
whole um anyway she got Wheaties what
are the classics great nuts they're
hanging in there they're on the bottom
shelf Grape Nuts his bottom shelf you
know there's still diff they're still
playing the [__] you know they're
playing the big rooms but not the a
rooms you know was another one that's
hung around for a long [__] time
waiting up flakes sort of Billy Carter
of the [__] great nut family all
right I'm done with this [__] [__]
anyways let's let's talk about what's
really important out there Nick DiPaolo
one of the [__] greatest comics I've
ever seen his new special is on right
now on seeso toi actually at 8:00 p.m.
tonight you got to [__] watch this
thing you don't have to but I would
really appreciate if you did it's called
inflammatory it's debuting today
February 16th and 8:00 p.m. on seeso TV
se ESO TV to subscribe to his pocket
podcast just go to canoe
to pal dot-com / Nick all lowercase
Connect pal co NN e CTP al.com / Nick
that's what I'm doing I don't know what
you're doing but that's what the [__]
I'm doing
Oh a Joey roses also has a special on
Comedy Central but Comedy Central is
weird because they don't stream they're
not weird they're old-school
you don't mean you know what they're not
streaming anymore so that channel
they're at Target right now Netflix
Netflix elbow timeout CISOs elbow that
they're the new the new though they're
like the Millennials of [__] TV
networks and they just cut in all these
[__] out you know and these other guys
watch commercials alright there's the
elephant in the room that I have to
address and I know every [__] French
[__] from Montreal with your silly socks
oh yeah clapping right now aren't you
huh
alright so as I you know not everybody
saw coming
you know Claude Julien was gonna take
the fall for some of the moves that
we've made and you know it'd have been I
was saying the entire [__] time that
this guy want us our first couple in
four years you know why are we blaming
this [__] guy yada yada yada please
don't [__] fire him what do they do
they fire him so I tweeted out
congratulations to any NHL team out
there that's looking for a great coach
that knows how to win a cup all right
now having said that I had no [__]
idea I had no [__] idea that the
Montreal Canadiens we're gonna fire
their coach was a terian they fired him
all right and [__] picked him up and
as much as I hate to say this is a
Bruins fan we [__] deserve it you
know I don't know you know what happens
is everybody does it they they were
doing well with Pat Burns and Pat burns
got [__] sick of him I always thought
Pat won a copy then 86 and 93 with him I
guess he did
existed in the middle like Don Mattingly
and I don't know I have no idea but I
think I'm gonna say it right now the
Canadians are gonna win a cup with
Claude Julien if before you get excited
you Montreal fans if they will win a cup
if their dumbass fans in the media don't
run them out of town first God knows
they love doing that [__] dopes
after you [__] up there you know what I
mean why don't you get out there and
skate around with you a little [__]
pocket square
[__] [__] moaning and complaining
the most arrogant fans on the face of
the [__] earth without a [__]
doubt of Montreal Canadian fans New York
fans are pretty bad but there's just
something about them that dumb you just
hear it they [__] breathe through
their mouths a big sandwiches they walk
around in sweatpants they get you know a
guy like Paul virzi who considers
dressing up putting on a new pair of
jeans and some Air Jordans and a sweater
I swear to God if Paul put that outfit
on he'd be like I'm ready to meet the
president okay that's your average New
Yorker but they've written so many songs
blowing that city that people think they
were cut above just because they you
know their parents had unprotected sex
they're you know all those songs William
will you make it anywhere most New
Yorkers can't even live outside of New
York they have a [__] panic attack
the second they get out of the - one two
seven one eight [__] area code
they're horrific
they hold on to it like they move out
here to LA and they keep wearing this
stupid [__] New York badge you know
like some washed-up athletes still
wearing his high school [__] jacket
they just can't they come out to LA and
all they do is [__] all over it's like
so go back you dumb [__] you know you're
gonna go back you're out here why don't
you enjoy it go learn how to surf go
have a [__] burrito go on a hike all
right already with the [__] New York
[__] oh the AG's [__] plays we did
the [__] leg we do the [__]
[__] Amsterdam I don't know look I'm
[__] I'm not gonna take
responsibility for anything they say in
this podcast first of all because I'm
not an adult and second of all cuz the
lack of sleep I've had recently yeah so
the New York fence there's still an
element of the of just you know they're
morons they're like Boston fence Philly
fans we're all mouth-breathing [__]
morons now the Canadian fence
okay the Canadian fence because they
don't live in the United States they
live in Canada they actually have to
take the time to learn about other
countries you know what I mean which
makes them appear to be more intelligent
but I'll tell you that some of the most
racist [__] people ever met my life
they lose a playoff series they burn
down their [__] City
they ran Patrick wah out of town okay
the [__] hornet's nest that claw
Julian just stepped into if they can
somehow keep those people at bay and
there's stupid-ass media the [__]
media those fed [__] like they're gonna
go out there and start skating if they
don't run them out of town I'm telling
you right now if all you [__] Montreal
[__] can guess just keep your [__]
Yap shut
okay go buy yourself another pair of
loafers and some silly [__] socks if
you can just shut your [__] mouth and
stop acting like you know how to run a
team this guy could bring you a cup I'll
tell you got a 50-50 chance cuz they're
not gonna be anything you know they
can't sit on their hands they can't they
speak French you know there's something
about speaking French all of a sudden
you think you know stuff unless you're
in France I want to go to France those
people look cool you go too much y'all I
don't know what the deal is so much of
that was just absolute misinformation
and I really enjoyed all of it
you know what congratulations to closed
elene I'm really happy went to another
original 16 I hate the [__] Canadians
but I'm adult enough to not tonight I
mean I I hope he wins another [__]
Cup I don't want the Canadians to do it
but I like him too much to [__] root
against them I'll only root against him
when it's hard cuz he's with the
Canadians but like obviously if the
Bruins are playing I'm gonna root
against them but uh he's just a [__]
class act you know he said he's gonna
keep the rivalry go
but he said something nice about the
players and all of that and we'll see
we'll see the only thing that can screw
this up is The [__] Canadian fans and
their media you know if you can run
Patrick wah out of town maybe this ends
the curse the curse of Patrick woth who
knows we shall see but I just became a
when he went to Montreal I just became a
huge Penguins in Washington Capitol fan
I will be rooting hard not against
cloade I just don't want to see the
[__] I love that they haven't won one
in twenty twenty four [__] years
they're going on a quarter of a century
for any other franchise that's totally
acceptable but not for them they have to
win a cup that's all they have
I one thing of sympathy I will say
actually I you know I love the City
Madre I'm [__] around you guys
beautiful women and you guys got [__]
in 1994 and that would have been so
great for baseball
if the Montreal Expos even made it to a
World Series forget about winning
winning the whole damn thing and they
had a young Pedro young Randy Johnson I
mean they were [__] stacked and I love
national league baseball my whole time
growing up whenever used to watch this
week in baseball it was always a faster
game it was hit and run they had all the
astroturf which I thought was cool when
I was a kid and you know I would you
know I watched the Red Sox we were all
American League week you see just keeps
signing one [__] home run hitter after
another another lefty okay if this guy
plays in Fenway Park he's gonna hit 80
home runs and all he did was just
grounded into double plays like the
pitcher doesn't know why he was brought
to town they just [__] blowing inside
hiding inside those [__] always loved
those pitches low the low ball they
[__] whatever the [__] they were don't
sink around my a big baseball guy they'd
always would ground out and then they
just work him right up the ladder and
that [__] high heat on the inside they
could never lay off it's G Red Sox
leaving another six runners stranded
it's not possible but that's what it
felt like to runners right
whatever I was never good at math
alright let's read some advertising here
shall we
all right frame bridge okay frame bridge
you have a thousand photos living in
your phone and not a single one in a
frame give your personal experience
using frame bridge calm I've never used
it why frame bridge what am I gonna do
frame a bunch of pictures and be taking
pictures of people who took their shoes
off on a plane I don't take pictures
like it but if you do take pictures if
this is this is for you because you know
what happens what ends up happening is
you lose your phone or your laptop craps
out and if you didn't put it on the
cloud then you're just gonna lose these
[__] photos like I know how many
photos I've taken with my cell phone I
don't I don't have any of them I don't
wear any of them are it's easy to use
evidently go to frame bridge calm choose
your frame or let their designers help
you choose upload your photo from your
computer or directly from Instagram
preview your photo online in the frame
you choose can't upload your photo art
no worries you can mail it in for free
instead of hunt the hundreds you'd pay
at a framing store their prices start at
$39 and all shipping is free plus my
listeners get 15% off their first order
at frame bridge calm when they use my
code burr be URR
go to frame bridge calm and use promo
code bar you'll save an additional 15%
off your first order just go to frame
bridge calm / / once again hey that's
frame bridge calm / bright mister
paragraph evidently they have an expert
team at frame bridge that will custom
frame your item in days not weeks or
month days okay that's way quicker than
weeks or months and delivery and deliver
your finished piece directly to your
door ready to hang fray bridge offers a
happiness guarantee the team gives each
item personal care and attention because
meeting your expectation is important as
meeting their own there you go they're
an old-school business they're gonna
treat you right frame bridge comm promo
code bar all right oh Jesus Christ but
Oh Popo me on DS be on DS Julian to the
Habs would do me andhis me undies all
the friends these are so glad they're
running around like a bunch of douches
with the silly socks in the pocket
squares but their [__] balls are nice
and soft just like their [__] morals
they're always outside their marriages
alright me undies elevate your underwear
game to the next level with me undies
you've perfected your wardrobe but what
about the stuff not everybody gets to
see if you've been setting settling for
store-bought underwear five packs I have
something that will change your life for
the better me undies one is beyond Esau
just seriously soft feel-good undies
delivered right to your [__] door the
undies are designed in LA and made from
sustainable source micro mode alpha oh
now it's micro modal a fabric three
times softer than cotton well how did it
become micro and still just as soft
there must have been a reason for it we
undies softer than soft softer than soft
smarter than smut luxury undies come in
an ever-changing selection of classic
colors bold shades and adventurous
patterns so you can tailor your undies
to your own personal style guess what
you can save time and money each month
with the monthly subscription how much
he is [__] yourself that you need to
get new underwear every month and if
you're not ready for subscriptions
that's okay you can still say that's
because me undies is offering you 20%
off your first pair just use our special
URL me undies comm slash bird to get 20%
off your first pair holy [__]
so go ahead revamp your underwear drawer
you deserve it once again that's my
undies dot-com slash burn the undies
calm slash burn all right mando Chino
Indochina talk about how a
made-to-measure suits fits compared to a
generic off-the-rack suit
well isn't that self-explanatory you
know unless you're a mannequin
measurements right what you're really
weird now you know what I mean they got
like the shredded ones they finally
don't just have all-white mannequins
they've let other races of people you
know that aren't allowed that aren't
alive to be allowed to [__] model
clothes
I don't need to talk about what
obviously hey if you just grab a random
[__] suit that sort of fits is that
not as good as having one that's [__]
tailor-made is one of the largest
made-to-measure menswear brands get high
quality get a high quality suit made to
your exact measurements for a perfect
fit yeah then you got to stop eating
we're not stop eating you got to keep
your calorie and take the exact [__]
same way you can get a custom you can
you also get to customize your suit just
the way you want it here's how it works
visit a showroom or shop online at endo
Chino comm IND o chai no CH Ino comm
pick from hundreds of fabrics choose
your customizations from lapels depletes
to jacket linings in more what are
pleats I know what lapels are aren't
pleats those [__] lines people used
to have in their pants in the 1980s
submit your and I'm not talking about
creases I mean the ones up near your
dick or your vajayjay as Oprah says
summit summit submit your body
measurements place your order and wait
for it it what it's gonna arrive at just
four weeks with this this week my
listeners can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for three hundred eighty nine bucks
Indochina calm at indochina calm when
entering bar at checkout this is perfect
if you're just entering the business
world you want to look good with the
[__] you know cheap suit you know I'm
not cheating a bad way but you know if
you don't to spend a lot of money that's
fifty percent off the regular place for
made-to-measure premium suit you can
customize it's known as the same one as
you plus shipping is free that's
Indochina know calm promo code bar for
any premium suit for just three or
eighty nine bucks and free shipping
incredible deal for a suit that will fit
you better than anything off the rack
ever could so there you go
they're affordable suits but they're
actually fitted like you're hosting the
Tonight Show or Late Night with Conan
O'Brien
well the Jimmy Kimmel show a talk show
all right we almost done here oh this is
the last one see so which tonight will
have nicked Apollo's new special at
eight pm
ever hear the saying laugh at the world
laugh in the world laughs with you
oh yeah I've had that but I'm not really
thought about it laughs in the world
lots yeah
stepping up bus and do that see what
happens so we laughing at you laugh and
the world laughs with you or at you
depending on the situation I think is
the way it should be alright anyways
well I hate to tell you but the world
has left you in the dust because they've
already signed up for sea so you know I
just blew their whole joke let me start
over again
everything is saying laugh and the world
laughs with you well I hate to tell you
but the world has left you in the dust
because they've already signed up for
sea so in other words they're already
laughing over there without you the
ad-free company streaming service with a
huge library of stand-up TV and original
content the world will be laughing
whether you join in or not so you might
as well get on board but see so you get
unlimited access to CISOs original
series Aziz's next day late night
hilarious stand-up specials binge worthy
classics including forty two seasons of
Saturday Night Live the entire Monty
Python catalog the it crowd and more
with see so Jason's got with a leaf
blower can you hear that with C so you
get binge worthy classics British coke
comedy original series like Harmon quest
and bazillion dollar prize property what
but Jillian oh but Jillian dollar
properties that's how you spell but
Jillian I didn't think that was a word
not to mention the entire SNL laborat
library including new episodes the day
after the air + C so brings stand-up
right to your living room with exclusive
content from today's best comedians
including Nick DiPaolo tonight at 8:00
on demand and commercial free sign up
now to catch brand-new stand-up specials
from Brian Posehn Nick DiPaolo and Joey
Diaz
hey brother women like doctors watch
your favorite sets from comedians like
louis c.k
Amy Schumer and Hannibal Buress access
see so content from anywhere at any time
using iOS Android Roku Apple TV Amazon
fire TV windows or Xbox one ready for
the punchline see so is just 399 per
month Jesus Christ I gotta sign up for
this [__] no joke 399
month for all the comedy you want
Anytime Anywhere ad-free I might do that
just to watch [__] all 42 seasons
just go to see so calm SCE s Oh calm
right now and sign up for one month for
free with promo code bar at checkout
this is the best offer see so has right
now one month for free of laughing your
ass off comedy at sea so just by using
promo code ber that's C so calm Jesus
Christ spelled se ESO compro micawber we
got it written again C SOCOM promo code
bar [__] alright it's over
hey speaking as much as a cloak Julian
has has left what's-his-face
Bruce Cassidy is undefeated and we beat
the Canadiens shut those [__] out for
nothing for two zip I didn't realize
Tuukka Rask was like oh nine and three
at the TD Banknorth Garden lifetime
against the Canadiens I had no idea he
had never won at home that's [__]
weird to me my baby was the other guy
came of his name was our goaltender we
won the [__] cop the guy would go to
White House and that took a year off to
go find himself and then I never heard
from him again
League went to the Panthers anyways
let's [__] plow ahead here shall we
um Oh Billy no booze no cigars it's
still [__] cruising along
I took my life insurance test and
[__] guy took blood Jesus because I
couldn't find the vein he [__] hacked
up my arm big time oh that's gonna
bruise a little bit and you know what he
was right but anyways I kind of liken
not smoking cigars I haven't smoked
since last year I like saying that so I
think I'm gonna go on a little run you
know no booze no cigar I'll take it
we'll keep your [__] sober you know
instead of looking fondly for that
[__] glass of scotch at night now all
you thinking about is oh my god when
this kid goes to sleep well this go kid
goes to sleep I'm going to sleep and I
am gonna [__] eat the whole [__]
another way that's all I care about
right now it's just getting a little bit
of sleep but uh but it's been [__]
awesome man already watched and change
and watching down now when she looks to
stuff she could really like kind of take
it in and I was still waiting for the
first
I still think it she just has gas if
she's going to the bathroom
he starts smiling and you think this
smiling at you and you're like oh my god
you smile at me and then you know you
kind of drift out in line of vision to
see if they're still looking at you and
then they just continue looking where
your head was and it's just like oh
alright I guess you're not so anyways
have I done my contractually obligation
obligated 33 minutes 30 minutes whatever
the [__] I'm supposed to do on this by
the way still loving my car loving it
more than ever
I had to put my truck in storage so what
I do is on the weekends I just drive my
car over to the storage I switch them
out and eventually eventually my next my
next house cuz the layout of my house I
don't know if this is gonna work with
one kid or if we decide to have another
one I don't know if it's gonna work out
cuz it's either we're upstairs and the
kids downstairs or we're downstairs and
the kids upstairs that just doesn't
[__] work out so I don't know maybe
I'll have to move I have no idea but I
will tell you this the next [__]
place that I move I don't give a [__]
about a view all I give a [__] about is
a [__] driveway that you know is
active that isn't built for a Model T
[__] fort that is built from modern
day cars I would love to have the
[__] circle driveway you know those
people like on Dallas well they'd have a
big [__] ranch you know they have
their own [__] streak just driving
all the way down there and just have
anything a little carport someplace in
my truck that debt is that's all like I
don't give it any when I picture my
dream house I don't even think about the
house all I think about is the driveway
the garage the garage I got a gym and I
got a [__] a little drum room you
know and I got a place for my truck in
my car and when I come out I don't have
to move like 20 [__] cars to get my
[__] car on I don't lose 20 I set my
car on my wife's car but I feel like a
valet you know that's all I give a [__]
about I don't give up I don't give a
[__] about the rest of the house that
the rest of the house is for your wife
they like that [__] this social
okay men need to get away from [__] and
I can have in this [__] garage all
right if I can just have a little place
where I can work out and I got a place
where I can play drums and I got my old
truck and I got my car and what the [__]
else do I need you know right there I'm
good
like I actually think my dream house is
just a garage with a room above it you
know and the garage has enough room for
two cars a modern and a classic the back
is the gym and then the drum room and
then upstairs is a little [__]
kitchen flat-screen TV right a little
[__] humidor and whatever the [__]
else you need do maybe that's you know
something all this whole downsizing in
life that's a [__] great idea oh [__]
the [__] divorced guys house that's
all it is and you just make an entire
[__] street you know so they can
still make their child support payments
they can still pay their alimony and all
they all these [__] women out there
whining about how they know that much
money yeah you dope you get your check
and his check so many of you do and
you're still going to those [__]
rallies standing out in the rain
listening to Alicia Keys this [__] out
of here
what Nia everything that I've said
you're gonna stare at me for that
I knew it listen to this idea come here
come here yeah
oh come on don't be like that come here
I have a great idea she goes don't be
like what an [__] like you ooh what
are we at the bus stop come here I'm
saying that that insult was on the level
of somebody standing at a bus stop oh
look at little cutie cakes what do you
say there I love how soft her feet
inhale huh
you have a daughter now so what does
that mean you know what that means yeah
it means I have to be extra funny
because now I got to you ladies I'm
paying for are you funny is this is this
what you consider funny move out of the
way I want to put her down
don't kiss me I try to make it cute oh
shut up listen
sit down I got an idea to force the
divorce guys house alright so all it is
is it's a two-car garage and in the back
there's a little gym if you play drums
like me there's a little drum room and
above it is just this just like almost
like a loft and that's your kitchen your
flat-screen TV your bed just the only
thing that you need because when I think
of our dream house I don't even think of
the house that's that's all I want is
that okay do you think that would work
if I had a whole street of [__]
divorcee divorced guys we're all paying
alimony all playing child support all
you strong women go into court and they
have to give no idea what anybody goes
through and divorce and having to get
alimony or any of that kind of stuff so
yes I do cuz I've divorced man I talk to
divorce men have you talked to any
divorced woman about it or you just yes
yes I did
oh I talked to a lot of them on Rodeo
Drive I'm in the money I'm in the money
I get my check and I get his [__]
check to down Kherson friend the baby
okay I'm in the money I'm in the money I
get my check and I get his freaking -
that's better huh you like that that was
take two you guys just got the edge -
I'll take all right I'm gonna look up
qgs all right um I gotta I gotta close
this up yeah thank you guys for for
listening I can't say this word for my
daughter you know what I say you you so
and so have a great weekend I'll talk to
you guys go after yourself go after
yourself don't take any s from anybody
I'll talk to you guys on Monday and
congratulations to close Julianne
forgetting the respect you deserved you
unemployed for what two or three days
best of luck to you even though you with
the Canadians unless you play in my
thoughts all right I'll see you
[Music]
don't bother jumping super-crazy field
star going through a dream
[Music]
hey what's going on it is Bilbo and it
is the Monday morning podcast for Monday
February 16th 2009 in the year of the
[__] what is it what is it the Europe
in China what animal is it
Shiva that's one of those dumb
conversations you have in a bar when
they'll have like a poster of lap on the
wall like what you you are born in you
were born the year of the monkey I can
see that
I can see that now certainly I can see
that shut up you dumb [__]
okay you don't have anything to say it's
okay to just not say anything you don't
have to just start looking at [__] on
the walls and trying to force a
conversation why don't you just stare
straight ahead and think about how you
ended up here you know how you can
change things in the future so you won't
have this screaming sound of [__]
regret in your head all the time to the
point that you're going to need to try
to drown it out with some stupid [__]
[__] about a poster on the wall in this
[__] bar oh god that's so good umm
it's raining out here right now in
California rainy days and Monday's
always get me down I [__] hated that
song who sang that song that was the
carpenters you know there's a woman
let's [__] get to where huh oh it's
raining out I think I'll go throw up my
breakfast let you fight that was that
was really really [__] me that was
really mean I apologize to the Karen
Carpenter's of the state for that one
I'm going to make a donation to the
bulimia fund you know what someone's
going to take that job really seriously
and I'm going to get some more [__]
hate mail which I get on these things
quite a bit sometimes quite a bit
sometimes how you like that I'd say
quite a bit I'm thinking in my head no I
really don't quite a bit it's actually
sometimes so I try to fix the lot but
anyway someone's going to [__] not
even the lie it was just like I was just
exaggerating
because you know that's just what you do
you know what I mean like you just
exaggerate you just get used to
exaggerating whatever the [__] it is you
do you know anyone doing right now doing
the exact thing I just was given that
hypothetical woman who's talking about
the poster in the bar I was giving her
[__] about doing it and then I turned
around I did it you know so now someone
else has to have a podcast trashing me
and that's how it starts did that make
sense I didn't think so
yeah so if you guys if you've never been
out here to California at least the
southern part of it people always you
know they talk about the weather out
here how it's like Groundhog Day how you
know every day is the exact same oh my
good if you did it 70 and beautiful
don't you get sick of it and I used to
be that person but I kinda I'm starting
to understand the weather out here and
it's pretty [__] fascinating
basically what happens is at the
beginning of the year usually against
this time of year around
you know January February it rains
almost every day for a month almost
every [__] day it rains and what it
does is obviously it builds up Jesus
I've really talked myself into a corner
here I really don't know what the [__]
I'm talking about but it's not gonna
stop me from plowing through this I was
like it's it builds up the shrubs and
green things like I didn't even know
what [__] word to use they're just
basically a Hollywood Hills you know
they usually like you know brown and
that type of [__] because we live in a
desert but after a month of this stuff
everything becomes really green and
really beautiful and uh you know then it
stops raining and then it's 70 degrees
out and everything's green and it's
[__] gorgeous out here but what
happens is over the over the course of
the year because we live in a desert all
that green [__] starts to turn brown and
it starts drying out and then when the
Santa Ana winds come across it drives
the [__] out of it and then that's
around fall and that's when we have
fires out here and the funny thing is is
the fires are completely natural people
out here for some reason they act like
they're [__] up like oh my god the
fire I just jumped over the world
five holy [__] what's going to happen
and we sit there we try to put the fire
out which we shouldn't be doing nature
is taking its [__] course it's
burning out all that green [__] and what
the firemen do is they put the [__]
fires out and they leave a bunch of
brown [__] you know that should have
burned up but now isn't and then next
year the fire is going to be even worse
and it's just the typical [__] like we
think it's a tragedy because nature is
doing what it naturally does and it's
not nature's fault some [__] idiot
built a house in the middle of [__] that
turns brown every year and catches on
fire you know what I mean would you know
would you sit in a fireplace would you
build a house in a giant fireplace I
wouldn't do that so what I'm trying to
say is the [__] living in the Hills
is overrated if you want to live down
here in the flatlands while the
apartment buildings out where one palm
tree catches on fire I mean the amount
of people jogging by with water bottles
can put that [__] up with those [__]
people who live up in the hills they're
crazy not to mention all the [__] the
soil dries out because there's so little
water right because we live in a desert
the soil dries out so like literally
like the top six inches is like [__]
bone-dry so then when it rains like this
that's what causes your mudslide because
evidently it can't absorb it it's like
dandruff and it just washes now and it
goes into the side of the guy's house
and I watch it on the news and I laugh
what the [__] what the [__] am I talking
about why do I read some stories I got
you know some I got a some I got some
great questions this week I got some
great stories and some great underrated
overrated I really feel like my 14
listeners which i think is actually up
to 22 I don't what the [__] it is I just
like saying 14 you guys are really up in
your game here and Oh before I get to
the stories everyone who submitted me
who made the finals for that DVD
competition could you please resend me
your addresses half of you have it too
you sent me your addresses and I lost
the emails because I'm a [__] [__]
but I don't want to get I don't to get
charged with some sort of I don't to be
unlike the news you know those
investigative reporting things you had a
podcast it was only doing okay
so I decided to give away some DVDs but
the DVDs never came I want it I want to
send them out so for the love of God all
right bill why don't you shut the [__]
up and read the story okay here's a
great story for you um you know I do my
whole little rants about the the
automated checkout lines in in grocery
stores and how I died they're [__] I
don't think it's technological
advancement its technical technological
advancement would be if I just walked up
and somehow I just stood there and
magically this machine knew what the
[__] I owed and then I paid and then I
left
that would be an advancement but to come
up with an automated machine where now I
go up there's no cashier and then I
become the cashier to me is not
technological advancements that's me
working at the grocery store for free so
one of my disciples who actually
believed in this said hey Bill here's
something that had me yesterday you
might appreciate he said I was in a stop
and shop yesterday so I'm guessing
that's East Coast right though let's go
to stop and shop get a [__] 30
practice rose dude I was in stopping
shop yesterday and just grabbing a
couple of things there was one lane open
and the four empty self check registers
so basically one lanes open with the
cashier and then there's four of those
automated things that are wide open and
so he says remaining remembering the
point you made in the podcast a few
weeks ago about the whole self check
concept I got back into the open line
behind five or six people I guess that's
a cashier line the girl who stays by the
self-check lanes came over and said she
noticed I only had a few things and that
I could just use the self checker and be
out of there quicker I just said no
that's okay I'm not going to do your
people's job for you after she heard
that she was like excuse me so I was
like
nothing I have no problem waiting I'm
just not doing your job for you
so she walks away and about a minute or
two later a manager comes over to me and
asked if there's a problem so I keep my
composure at this point and tell him
there's no problem then I just rather
wait online then ring up my own stuff he
then goes on to tell me that his
employee told him that I was being rude
and disrespectful and that he was going
to ask me to leave the store I said to
him are you serious I didn't even raise
my voice I just told her I'd rather wait
in line and that the other people online
standing next to me can vouch for me of
course when he asked the other people
what happened nobody said a goddamn word
to defend me because I was apparently in
a line with a group of Helen Keller's
typical spineless [__] [__] right
so this is his final point he says I
understand that the girl was just trying
to help me out by suggesting that I use
that line to get out of the store
quicker but when I calmly told her that
I was fine she didn't have to make up
some [__] story to spite me when the
day comes when cashiers are phased out
and all there is a self-check registers
and that [__] is out of a job I will
have a nice chuckle to myself you know
something Mike I can't get married on
that one I actually got annoyed by that
girl and if she lost a job but you know
I don't know I think you're right on
that one although I got to admit you
know you you know to use the narrows
line in Goodfellas you yeah you insult
it a little bit a little bit you kind of
insulted her you got to go nice to next
time and just say listen you know what I
mean I don't want you to lose your job
those two those machines are taking your
job and I don't want to be a part of
that so I'd rather stand in line here so
you guys can keep making a paycheck if
you set it that way but you kind of went
a little bit a little bit with a little
hostile and you were like yeah I'm not
doing your job for you you know I mean I
don't know did you have you know so go
[__] yourself tone I have no idea but
you know something I totally back you
when you think that you know
well I would have been livid in that
situation I wouldn't have been able to
control myself when that manager came
over I would have been like I didn't say
anything and I would swim in like you
know these machines are [__] at that
point I would a curse and be like I'm
sighs you need it you need to leave the
store so that make any sense it's like I
agreed with you and I scolded you I
agree with you when she doesn't have a
job I'll be [__] happy too and you
know I don't know I don't what the well
that says that that's a rough one
that is a rough one I'm just [__] out
of it today I don't real [__] bad
time last night at comedy clubs I had
two different people coming up to me
saying [__] like you know I'm not gonna
[__] say it's just one of those
things where another comic comes up to
you and as they compliment you on a joke
you know that they're going to steal it
you know they do that [__] you know you
know I really like that joke you did
about the blah blah blah blah blah you
know it's just amazing you know when I
watch comics all the different takes
people have on things let me guess your
take is the same as my take except you
switch to words you [__] [__]
alright next story a bill thanks for
driving that [__] hybrid this is always
nice to read on a [__] Monday hey Bill
thanks for driving that [__] hybrid
every bit you guys save ensures that
that ensures just that much more for me
to use in my muscle car was wondering if
you've got something that looks like a
car or did you get the one shaped like a
butt plug all kidding aside I dig your
stand-up podcast all that [__] awesome
no hybrid looks like a butt plug I
actually I don't know what a butt plug
looks like I imagine it looks like
something that you stick in the sink and
then what a butt plug looks like I like
how he's calling me a [__] but he knows
what a butt plug looks like you know
something I'm gonna chime in early on
the underrated overrated you know what's
overrated muscle cars muscle cars are so
[__] overrated it's ridiculous have
you seen those things those auctions
they have
these [__] baby boomer geek [__]
rich douchebags are spending like a
hundred and fifty grand to get a 68
Mustang the [__] is wrong with you
[__] idiots probably can't even
change the oil they want to go in there
and get the you know the body off
restoration playing a hundred and fifty
[__] thousand dollars for a Mustang
the Mustang you know what I mean if
[__] idiot you can literally go buy a
piece-of-shit Mustang you know that
piece of [__] but it's got a decent body
and just throw a new [__] engine in
it why would you spend a hundred fifty
grand or that it's got the original or a
roll the window down handles you know in
1968 these will actually shut up it's
not worth 150 grand those cars are so
[__] grossly overpriced those are
overpriced those vintage guitars of
theirs any musicians those [__]
beat-up [__] fenders and Les Paul's
from 4050 years ago that you know you
can't play you can't [__] play
there's no reason there's no guitar
that's worth fifty [__] thousand
dollars and they got the [__] kicked out
of him they're all worn out they look
like [__] I don't understand it so he
bought the point the other day well as
Stevie Ray Vaughan he used to play an
old guitar he got in a pawn shop
I paid [__] thirty bucks for it could
tell you right not that thing was 50
grand he would been playing a ukulele on
the Texas Flood album um but anyways I
why do people think they're so manly if
they have a muscle car I don't [__]
understand it it's like you can get one
for 15 grand it's not like I couldn't
afford to buy one but I just [__]
idiot and it just automatically makes
you gay I gotta mince the little tires
just a little tires and make it [__]
and you know what the guys right they
are [__] they are [__] look I don't
know if they look like blood plugs you
know all right you know what
at the risk of having the FBI come to my
door to find out what I'm doing I'm
actually going to go on the internet
right now and I'm going to [__]
Google Images butt plugs
you know what I picture I picture like I
really picture like a little plug and it
has like the threads like you literally
screw it in and then it's got that
little metal ring you just see this sort
of pull it out alright is but with two
butt plug
I'm gonna have to [__] burn this
[__] iPod after I do this images all
right but plug search images for a butt
plug here we go Jesus Christ that looks
like a [__] grenade custom but
there's a paris hilton butt plug and
it's it's shaped like a hand oh my god
he's a horrific foxtail butt plug
there's a family circus roof with a
buttload wow these are creepy sex toys
are creepy okay these are gross and to
save you guys well I can't explain what
they look like
I guess they look like if I look like
Christmas trees with the stand that's
the only way I can I can describe it
it's the same shape
that's gross that's [__] gross see
but see the level you just [__]
brought this podcast down to is really
disgusting um anyways we know something
the audio of this will save me if the
FBI comes I'm like Pete Townsend I was
just doing research all right next one a
bill I saw you on Comedy Central in
December and I've been listening to you
ever since I know how strongly you feel
people what the [__] is this
using the self-checkout which I agree
with and I was wondering how you feel
about people paying bills online this is
a great question how do you what do you
feel about people paying bills online
I'll tell you what I feel I think you're
out of your [__] mind if you pay your
bills online I know it's easier and it's
more convenient but you know that
[__] where they sit there and they
try to say like this is a completely
secure site you don't have to worry but
the day this [__] nerds out there
breaking into the [__] computer at
the Pentagon yesh you should never pay
your bills online you shouldn't buy
anything online you shouldn't do any of
that you're rolling the dice cuz I'm not
gonna lie to you I do it I do it but
every time it's [__] stupid I I won't
pay my bills online I certainly won't do
that online banking you're going to put
your [__] your give balance if you're
[__] account number all of that [__]
you're going to put that online yet
you're out of here you're out of your
mind you're out of your mind but this
guy's basically saying uh probably
beating a dead horse but the less mail
that needs to be delivered the less
carriers they need my brother is a mail
carrier
and it [__] pisses me off that people
don't want to pay 42 cents to mail a
letter I mean come on I'm a tight-ass
myself but you can't you can't buy [__]
with 42 cents what do you think I don't
know man email email people back and
forth I mean there is an element of
technology to it but I will tell you
this like I will forever pay bills by
you using uh the mail I mean a mailman I
just I don't know it just seems I mean
not saying that people can't [__] with
your mail but I don't know I think
you're out of your [__] mind if you
at the very least if you do your banking
online you're out of your [__] mind
unless you don't have [__] anyway so you
know any money gives a [__] right that's
one of the great things about being
broke you know when you want to punch
someone in the face you can you know
what to worry about getting soup I guess
you got to worry about going to jail and
you can't afford a good lawyer I don't
want the [__] I'm talking about um
anyways let's talk about Shep coming up
um I'm going to be at wiseguy comedy
club uh this weekend in Ogden Utah and
this is my the first time I've ever been
out I did a college here a number of
years ago but I can't remember the last
time I was out when the [__] was I on
Utah I don't remember but anyways it's
the show is on February 20th and the
website is WWF guys comedy comm if
you're on my website you can click on
the link it's right to the left-hand
side of the page and clicked on Ogden
I'm going to be there for one night one
night only two shows and and that's it
wait a second what the [__] are they
saying here in the website oh they got
it right they got it right so there you
go so if you saw me on Comedy Central
wrote a whole new [__] hour and yeah
so all you Mormons whatever hell you
guys are out there you BYU fans come on
out to the show and I'll make you
[__] laugh and then I'll go back to
my hotel room and stare out the window
wonder what happened it's actually a
scary place to land if I remember
correctly Salt Lake City is surrounded
by mountains so they kind of have to fly
over them and the
ii do like a military landing just drop
like 10,000 feet I believe alright here
we go let's get into the podcast
questions for the week for the week all
right bill question number one every now
and then every now and again on shows
like Access Hollywood Entertainment
Tonight or X or extra they let the
everyday working-class person know how
much television and movie stars make
every time I hear the ungodly amounts
I'm disgusted as well I should be
alrighty
fully understanding the gluttony
involving the government and the banks
what about these repulsive repulsively
overpaid stars I don't why you comparing
celebrities to banks that stole from
everybody's 401k you know what's the
worst the star can do put out a movie
hype it say it's good you're out ten
bucks you know what I mean
and they usually most of them fall off
after three years and I don't know I
don't think they're grossly overpaid I
think they are overpaid because the
actors underneath them don't make as
much as they used to and the main person
I guess gets most of the money but you
know look if you [__] make a movie
and you have me star in it or you have
Tom Cruise star in it you know I mean
you can't say Tom Cruise isn't worth the
[__] money you put Tom Cruise in it
it's guaranteed the [__] thing's
going to make 100 million dollars
basically been doing that for 25 years I
don't think that that guy's overpaid so
I don't agree with that I don't think
that you could you know government
stealing money and bank stealing money
you can say that celebrities I don't
know I don't think that's the same thing
not to mention celebrities have no
privacy what's so [__] ever and I
think they get paid right about what
they deserve because when you get to
that level of Fame you need a huge house
with the wall around it you need your
own movie theater you need your own
tennis courts because you can't [__]
go anywhere you know because eventually
you're going to have to pick your nose
and it's going to be on the cover of a
magazine so you need you know to
want to foot shrubs so you can
comfortably get the underwear out of
your ass and do what [__] human
beings do does that make any sense all
right bill I watch a lot of stand-up
comedy I critique it to death
I analyze the joke delivery wording
timing everything to decide what could
have been done differently to make it
funnier when I watch you perform
everything you do and say seems to be
spot-on and it went perfectly planned I
was wondering when you watch your own
specials do you find parts that you are
unhappy with or feel you could have done
much better or differently yeah the
whole [__] thing I want when I go to
edit it I watch it one time I watch it
one time with one eye closed and and
then I never watch it again I'm gonna be
one of those people like if I ever get
my own TV show I will never watch one
episode of it yeah it's it's not a
[__] natural thing to see the back of
your head or see what the side of your
face looks like or to hear what your
voice sounds like Oh to watch you hold
in a glass it's it's not natural to be
outside of yourself watching yourself
it's just [__] you know you haven't
it's like this outer body experience
it's just it's [__] weird and I don't
know if you're comfortable doing it I
don't I think that's I don't know more
power to you but I can't [__] do it
so yeah I always think I think about
stuff all the time
well my you know certain times may feel
special and III dealt with that one was
uh that one wasn't too hard to watch
because that one went great why do I do
this wasn't too hard to watch but those
I only watch them one time but like a
bunch of [__] earlier earlier on in my
career you know it is it's when it's on
TV that's when it freaks me out like if
I film myself last night you know at the
comedy store or whatever I could go home
and I could watch it and I wouldn't have
a problem watching and I could actually
enjoy it but the second I know it's
going to be on TV and the [__] cell
phone it's my girlfriend cell phone huh
California dreamin okay
that why hey [__] phone anyway I wasn't
going to say yeah so but the second I
know it's going to be on TV that's when
it freaks me out and then I'm like oh my
god you know anywhere from [__] a
thousand people to [__] whatever how
many people [__] watch Comedy Central
however many of that is are gonna see
this [__]
and then everything I do any little
screw-up that I do becomes you know nine
hundred feet tall and I freak the [__]
out and probably comes down to the fact
that I don't like myself ah that sad so
why don't you like yourself um working
on it all right bill what would you
attempt to this is person ask me a bunch
of new agey questions what would you
attempt to do if you knew you would not
fail uh jump off a tall building you
know I guess I would fail by jumping up
jumping off a building and living you
know I don't feel what that adrenaline
rush feels like is you like that cuz
you're going down I do something like
that
um I know that person wanted something a
lot deeper than that let me see here
what would you want me to attempt to do
if you knew you would not fail uh what
would I do
uh Jesus Christ I'd probably try to do
some Gandhi [__] you know if I wouldn't
get assassinated I wish I had that kind
of charisma if I could lead a Gandhi
revolt against these [__] automated
cashier machines you know I shoot small
you know what I mean
Gandhi you know what did he get he got
England to [__] leave India what what
thanks does he get he gets shot in the
back of the [__] head or at least Ben
Kingsley did I never I don't know much
about the real Gandhi actually you know
it's funny when I picture Gandhi I
picture Ben Kingsley as Gandhi number
two bill you had two identities if you
had two identities one is yourself and
one is an animal what kind of animal
would you be you know something I feel
like I'm in a really bad date right now
what kind of animal would I be something
that could run the [__] away really fast
from these questions if I could be one
animal I need to be a bird because I've
always wanted to fly what kind of animal
died be something poisonous so I could
[__] bite you on your ankle no that's
mean I know what's my favorite animal I
like bears yes so stupid question number
three bill what is one of the most
valuable lessons you have learned so far
to proofread the questions know what is
I'm really trashing this person these
are good questions you know what
don't don't don't be stiff you if you're
the person who wrote this you listen to
me right now don't feel bad that you
wrote these okay this has nothing to do
with you this has to do with me
and all of a sudden you're tapping into
an emotional level in me that I'm not
comfortable exposing alright this is
feeling like I have to relax and open up
and it's just really [__] creeping me
out all right let me [__]
white-knuckle my way for this last one
bill what is one of the most valuable
lessons you have learned so far
whether you learned it watching someone
else go through the situation or you
expected it yourself experienced it
yourself oh I would say that life
doesn't have to be hard that you don't
have to be miserable and that you don't
have to be surrounded by a bunch of
[__] and that if that's how you grew up
you know without even realizing it you
go out into the world and you surround
yourself with those same kinds of people
just because you're used to it and then
maybe one day you get to what I figured
out about a year ago is like hey you
know I really don't have to hang out
with a bunch of [__] you know I
think that's why so many marriages don't
work out because you just want to get
away from your family and then you go
out and you end up marrying the exact
same kind of [__] I was just having a
conversation last night over a couple of
beers you know whatever misery you grew
up with if you're not careful you go out
and you marry it
you know expecting change don't don't uh
I guess that's what I thought I came to
say I learned it I noticed it I noticed
that I was like hey look at that [__]
over there
all right good that's stuff if you guys
really want to freak me out ask me some
new agey questions and that'll be a new
section of the podcast we get to watch
me squirm and be [__] uncomfortable
probably up to right now 29 minutes all
right I'm gonna try to keep these a
little bit shorter here all right hey
Bill have you ever gotten revenge on a
person on an object or an object like
printer in office space that movie um I
got a mitt I'm not a big revenge person
I don't feel comfortable with it I
always like that goes to a really dark
dark place that's like yeah you holding
the hand of the devil when you when you
do some [__] like that like I I walk
away if someone really [__] me over
I just lesson learned I walk away like
I've never uh you know you know if I
ever dated a girl and she [__] me over
something I just always I just said [__]
it I walked away it's just not worth it
it's not worth it I'm not doing it and I
know me is not only you know have I just
gotten [__] over and now I'm going to
seek revenge in this odds are that I'm
going to get caught seeking revenge and
that's the worst because that's like one
time I had like I went our first time I
lived out here in LA I came back from
being on the road for two weeks and
there was it there was a note on my door
saying that that they needed to check my
smoke alarms and that they needed to
check them by this certain date and by
the time I got off the road the date was
literally like a week earlier right so
evidently they had the legal right to go
into my apartment because if there was
my smoke detectors you know our faulty a
fire my apartment affects the other
units that was their reasoning so I
walked in there I could just immediately
tell that someone had been in my
apartment and this only feels back in
the day when I really did the road for a
long time like when I came back
you know from the I've been on the road
so long like all the water it basically
evaporated out of my toilet you know
what I mean those like half an inch of
water like that type of [__] right and I
was sitting there and I sat down I was
like [__] eat I don't know what it
was some sort of say ESPN I'm with the
[__] proper term is but I could just
feel it I was like something's not right
and I got up and I looked through my
apartment and I was mentioned missing a
camera I was missing a watch and the
person had picked through my CD
collections evidently they were a rap
fan because that's all they took and you
know nickel and dime [__] so I went
downstairs to the management and I was
like you know I come back from being on
the road you say going to check my smoke
detectors and I walk in there missing to
watch mrs. CDs I'm missing cameras the
place is still locked from the inside
and the guy immediately just snapped on
me so look I don't appreciate you coming
down here accusing boo-boo-boo-boo-boo
oh my god accuse anybody I didn't accuse
anybody I don't appreciate you standing
here getting upset with me like on this
guy just he totally tried to guerilla
his way through the [__] and at one
point he's just like whatever he's like
I have the power I have the power he
literally said that and I want to reach
across and just rip this guy's [__]
throat out
so my girlfriend at the time goes you
know who the guy is um I guess she goes
you know where his car is yes she goes
you should go down and [__] up his car
and I really thought about doing it but
I was like all right you just went down
to the guy's office you just had a
really heated argument with that [__]
guy there was people there witnessed it
you know what I mean there's cameras in
the garage if I do it I know I'm going
to get [__] caught so actually I did
get revenge what am I talking about I
know what I did instead I stood outside
the office and
[Music]
what did i do that's no no I think it
was still part of the argument someone
came walking in and they were getting
ready to rent an apartment in the
building and I told him the story I go
and I came back off the road and his
stuff missing and I'm talking to this
guy and this guy's yelling at me I'm
telling you the elevators too slow and
the two people like thanks a lot and
they walked out and then I looked at the
guy and I said let me tell you something
I'm a comedian I don't work days I will
sit out here every single day in a
launcher and I'll tell every person
comes walking in there and I saw the guy
get nervous and I knew I was completely
full of [__] because I had to go in on
the road again the next day and so yeah
I never seek revenge and it still bugs
me and I try to lie to myself going you
know what he'll get his that guy will
get his and you know what I've realized
those guys don't get this they continue
to rob and steal but I know maybe
they're miserable do you guys believe in
that [__] do you think that they don't
rent vengeance --is mindset it's the
Lord do you believe in that [__] I kind
of believe in it and then other than
sometimes I think well didn't just some
rich people write the Bible so I would
feel comfortable being poor yeah we [__]
you over
don't take vengeance on us don't worry
this invisible guy after we'll dead
we're dead he'll take care of us that's
the one thing why I don't believe in the
Bible because everyone who preaches it
is living this this lifestyle that they
would not get into heaven
you know like George Bush George Bush is
a Jesus Freak that guy's out of his
[__] mind you know is that his
[__] mind would Jesus you know
somehow take us to war I'm not trying to
get political here not saying the guy
did the right thing of the wrong thing I
don't [__] know but I'm just saying
you know if I was truly a Jesus Freak I
would not advocate going to war and one
of the things that scares me about
[__] people get into religion is the
more religious they get the more violent
and unaccepting they get of other people
that is one of the most happiest things
I've ever said because other people made
that point but it's [__] true it's
true like I don't give a [__] about gay
guys you know they can [__] blow each
other all day long what the [__] do I
care they're not hurtin anybody you know
I don't want to see it
but we have laws against that don't blow
your boyfriend out the [__] Street
you know but I think you ought to be
able to do it on a futon you know behind
some walls I don't think you're going to
hell I mean for me it'd be a whole
hellacious experience but you know right
just continue one bill you made your
point and now you're going to ruin it
all right plow ahead all right hey Bill
on TV they sometimes talk about how it
cost 11 trillion dollars to have Chris
Rock come to your house and do 15
minutes of stand-up how much will it
cost to have Dilbert come over to a fans
house and perform stand-up for 50
minutes what a great [__] question
it would cost you I do it for I do it
for 12 bucks but I would have some
writers attached to it that would up the
performance price okay first off there
has to be some sort of stage okay and it
literally could be that brick part that
comes out from your fireplace I'll stand
on that or maybe an ottoman you know
what's an ottoman is that the thing you
put your clothes in or is that the thing
you put your feet on I'm talking about
the thing you put your feet on one of
those things and also I have to be
helicoptered in you have to have a
backyard as big enough is big enough for
me to land in okay and then I'm going to
get off the helicopter and I'm going to
be wearing a scarf silk scarf that you
pay for that I will never address during
my performance no one at the party is
allowed to make eye contact with me
everyone will sit around the [__]
Ottoman oh that thing you put your feet
on Indian style
and I will do my jokes and I will not
look at any I will I will [__] be
staring at the toaster the entire I want
to toaster in the back of the room I
will do this for 12 bucks
you pay me $12 you helicopter me in you
buy this scarf I will stand on a [__]
ottoman and I will do I'll do 25 minutes
by 12 bucks all right you got the
[__] 12 bucks and the money to book
the helicopter I will do it I'm really
talking myself into a [__] YouTube
moment
and that's it but no one can make eye
contact with me just like Papa Greenwich
Greenwich Village and you don't say good
night to nobody
that way she gotta stare at the [__]
floor when she walks out jam em you know
some that's that's the tandem I'm
waiting to get back together
everybody talks about Walter Matthau and
Jack Lemmon back in the day what about
Mickey Rourke and Eric Roberts can they
get together again
Mickey Rourke is back I think it's time
for those guys to do another [__]
movie before the two goddamn old so
there you go there's your answer 12
bucks a helicopter ride no eye contact a
scarf and a [__] ottoman you got
yourself a comedian but not for 15
minutes all right
give me 24 bucks I'll do the 50 minutes
all right here we go
overrated underrated okay underrated how
awesome whoever the first guy was to
coin the phrase mustache ride I have to
admit I've never heard of this dis
phrase how much confidence and
creepiness does one have to use in order
to say something like that to an actual
living breathing woman probably happened
sometime during this the 70s when
everyone was sporting a mustache in a
leisure suit oh is that we did back in
the day actually I'd like to take a
mustache ride I don't I've never heard
of that one um oh here's a good one
underrated what red wine will do to your
erection true story a while back I had a
girl over for dinner at my place I drank
about three glasses of wine I was
expecting to make out with her it was
kind of a first date so I wasn't
expecting the opportunity to get laid
7/10 ly this guy kept drinking so while
the opportunity arose to get laid and I
didn't I was sitting on the edge of my
bed pulling my dick like I was trying to
get an old lawnmower to start and
nothing you know embarrassing this to be
jerking off in front of a girl while
apology I think
I've been there I can never look that
girl the eye again I've heard the term
whiskey dick but never heard a mention
of red wine how come no one ever told me
that that could happen
I think whiskey dick just sort of was
supposed to be all encompassing of
alcohol in general I think whiskey dick
I guess has a decent ring to it beer
dick doesn't sound good wine dick
actually whiskey dick doesn't sound good
either I never liked that either I don't
like that expression maybe some sort of
alliteration going on there or beer [__]
that's not good wine Willy Willy Willy
wine oh I don't know what it is but with
no whiskey dick means all alcohol but no
one ever explained that because I you
took it literally like oh don't drink
whiskey I won't be able to get an
erection but evidently I can drink
[__] red wine all night like some
[__] divorced 48 year old woman with
two kids what's wrong with you was a man
that you said that drinking red wine was
that very idea were you wearing a scarf
I bet you were you should have been
helicoptered in if you have bottle of
red wine all right overrated how excited
people get over getting their tax refund
you know something that's one of the
best overrated ever that's a [__]
great one and some was like I'm getting
3,000 back from the government 2000 back
from the 16,000 they took from me
throughout the year and the kicker is
that while I was sitting in my
accountants office I don't really use
government I realized I don't really use
government services I don't have any
kids in school I live in New York City
so I don't drive on state roads I'm 27
and I've never needed a cop throughout
my whole life I never called the fire
department
I've never been on welfare the only
thing the government has done for me in
the past year is pick up my garbage and
make sure I get more HD channels I
realized I have to pay taxes and
ultimately I don't mind doing it but in
hindsight 13,000 is way too much to pay
to have someone take away your garbage
that's more than a thousand bucks a
month I could drive a top-of-the-line
Lexus
for that type of money yeah and put your
garbage in the trunk and take it over
the dump exactly well you know what the
funny thing is about people getting
their tax refund back they're all
excited and they don't have to think
that you gave the government an
interest-free loan like you could have
had that three grand plus the money that
you owed the government sitting in your
bank account or whatever earning
interest and then the end of the year
you can just give them the money that
you owed them you should what is that
you claim zero is that what it is that's
what you should do and then you get some
sort of psycho accountant to whittle the
[__] charges down and then you Pam
that's how you do it you know what as
most people they don't want to deal you
know and they just kind of look at dude
it's money in the bank no it isn't it
isn't money in the bank
it's money lost that's what it is and
then what do they do when they get their
[__] money back what do they do they
go out and they take it and they go out
and buy a shiny liability dad I went on
a BA reflective flatscreen did what I
did that's great that's great he
realized the second you hung it on your
wall it's worth six hundred bucks now
you dumb [__] underrated mom-and-pop
hardware stores emailing classic Bruce
Lee kung fu movies and good girls good
girls are so underrated so underrated
why do we always pick the horse fellas
huh why you know why because you dick
you dick it's give [__] dick I didn't
explain it I don't need to explain it it
just goes back to that dumb Discovery
Channel thing the same way the Lions you
know the lionesses are sitting there and
when they look at the herd do they go
after the best gazelle no they go after
the weakest one because it's the easiest
kill so what it is it's [__] what it
is all right overrated giant corporate
stores iPhones Jackie Chan movies and
Valentine's Day really one day out of
the year where the price of roses teddy
bears and chocolates skyrockets because
some naked baby wants to fly around
shooting arrows and people's asses just
surprise your girl
on a random day with that [__] she won't
expected and will appreciate a hundred
times more than if you did it on
Valentine's Day could not agree with you
more I gotta say something you guys are
really up in your [__] game here you
know great questions great underrated
overrated great stories I mean I didn't
have to do [__] this week I just sat
here and [__] read it like a [__]
local newscaster which is kind of good
because I think I was kind of off my
game today sitting here my freezin
[__] cold apartment I got this awful
heater in order mean ceiling that my the
place where I live in is a really cool
building but it's old as [__] it's like
one of those old-time Hollywood you know
back when it said Hollywood land that's
when this thing was built it was made in
the late 1930s I like living in old
places like that but the you know sucks
the heat him I always like think about
the conversations you know what I mean
I like [__] that happened like you know
I bet Charlie Chaplin came over here and
bang some wannabe starlet in my shower
his little Hitler mustache getting all
[__] wet you know I just pictured
Charlie Chaplin still wearing that
[__] that hat and making that I'm
[__] you real good face you know you
bite your lower lip he's probably all
nervous too because what happened to
Fatty Arbuckle but he still had to do it
you know because he didn't pick a good
girl he didn't he went over here and
[__] Oh [__] you know that's what I
always we ever wonder about you ever get
an old apartment you just wonder what
the [__] happened you know like this
this place was around like right before
World War two all the conversations that
had taken place all that stuff the
amount of people from different
generations bitching about how this
heater doesn't work I don't know the Red
Scare Kennedy get whacked the white
flight in Detroit I don't know why I
just brought that up you know why cuz a
guy who [__] shaves my heads from
Detroit and he lived through all that
Detroit is such a sad [__] City this
guy was telling me how back in the day
some of the richest people in the world
lived in Detroit back when the big three
was the big three and the Ford family
they all lived there and because they
had all this cash all these great
department stores all these museums in
Detroit look at it years later
eight-mile mmm
Kid Rock please angry [__] white kids
because they grew up in a [__] BFI
bin
what's a BFI been bill well that's the
name of the [__] waste management in
Massachusetts a garbage dump dumpster
right all right I guess that's that's
you know I had rainy Monday energy on
this one but we can do you can't have a
[__] about these [__] things because
they're free all right and if you are go
[__] yourself get cheap [__] you know
I've actually had young people criticize
my podcast don't was as good as last
week's really do you feel cheated out of
money you [__] [__] you know it hard
it is to babble by yourself
Wow all the way up to 47 minutes
I really have diarrhea the [__] mouth
here alright let me get off the phone
here alright so here here are some of my
upcoming gigs I have a gig on [__] what
is the [__] date of it why no I mean
Ogden this weekend and I'm going to be I
have an LA date coming up hang on hang
on let me open it up where the [__] is
it I don't know what the [__] it is [__]
I'm gonna be at the Comedy Store do want
to show on oh I know I go into my cell
phone here this is garbage time right
now
Irvine what I guess I'm with me and
Irvine the Irvine improv on February
24th is that right you know what are the
information next week it will be no big
deal but I got a couple of LA shows
coming up you know what I have to call
somebody right now you wanna hear me
call and ask somebody about what the
[__] when my next gig is is your life
that empty you really is that how much
you hate your [__] job
you're actually gonna listen to this
phone call it is isn't it you got to do
a gut check right now who is that
computer lady please enjoy the music
while your party is reached come on hold
right now hang on hey Jeff what am i
doing that show with you at the Comedy
Store February 26 okay cool all right I
just need to put it I want to put on my
website right now all right okay all
right I'll look I'm doing good I got
somebody on the other line let me call
you right back okay bye huh you like
that all right
February 26 I'm going to be at the
Comedy Store and it in Los Angeles doing
Jeff Richards show it's a show to help
benefit hungry people people don't have
any food you know and it's not starving
people either it's just you know I give
up it's been driving around town like I
[__] I'm starving
those kinds of people people who
actually like have eaten that day but
they haven't eaten in six hours so they
feel like they're starving we're
actually gonna help them out you know
because everybody's helping out those
starving kids in Africa anybody can do
that [__] who actually helps out
starving people who technically aren't
starving they just haven't eaten in a
while and their bodies are now breaking
down the muscle that they built up at
the gym all right thank you very much
for listening please keep the great
podcast questions coming the underrated
overrated the movie reviews call on my
car [__] whatever the [__] you want to
do and that's it oh look at the Sun came
out right at the end of the podcast
isn't that beautiful Sparky next week
bye
of all colors place golden
[Music]
not of words for them su sunday fell in
the shower burns the evil week palace of
the Queen
[Music]
husband and he's like sitting there
sipping tea with the wife
you